quando nós falamos das cidades sejam
elas sobre qualquer das dimensões ou
apropriações sejam científicas humanas
sejam sob a ótica físico territorial
seja sobre a ótica política em comum o
que nós temos quando falamos de cidades
duas grandes categorias uma o espaço
ou seja esse espaço ele é dominado
transformado incorporado ressignificado
a partir da segunda grande dimensão que
a dimensão tempo ou seja a partir das
técnicas tecnologias apropriações sobre
o nosso meio nós transformamos esse
espaço
nós nos apropriamos dele de uma maneira
diferente e hoje num contexto de
espalhar novas idéias ou espalhar é
contradições e espalhar também
discussões muito provocativo tema
proposto para esta palestra sobre
cidades inteligentes porque não é só as
cidades que estão parece inteligentes no
bolso de vocês nesse momento aí vocês
têm um smart devices tem um smartphone
na casa de vocês
o smart tv nós parece que esse termo
smart inteligente ele está servindo como
adjetivação de tudo né
e esse cuidado que a gente tem que ter
com isso porque nós não estamos falando
aqui simplesmente de um objetivo
nós não estamos falando simplesmente do
que a inteligência não estamos falando
de cidades feitas por pessoas e ao falar
sobre cidades inteligentes
grande parte das discussões sejam elas
inclusive para serrano que as cidades ou
quais são as dimensões de uma cidade
inteligente um dos pontos que em comum
ao falarmos sobre cidades inteligentes
são sensores conectores
você já deve ter ouvido falar até data
da internet das coisas
dispositivos que se conectam transfer
informações tão novas informações mas a
gente não falou de espaço e tempo que
integrados geram conhecimento
então dentro desse conceito de
inteligências e nino tipos de
inteligências talvez uma inteligência e
seja fundamental para o entendimento das
cidades do território e mais o
território como poder
a transformação do território em lugar
em espaço de vivência
nós estamos falando aí da inteligência
geográfica e quando nós falamos aí
alguns de vocês devem estar em algumas
dessas redes sociais
espero que não em todas ao mesmo tempo
né o que essas redes sociais têm corre a
informação espacial a informação
geográfica e aqui eu queria me apropriar
do geógrafo yves lacoste não tinha
hashtag naquela época ainda né
mas em 67 é o título de uma obra sua que
diz a geografia
serve esta serve antes de mais nada para
fazer a guerra
então quando nós estamos falando de
inteligência geográfica ou seja unirmos
geografia com tecnologia nós estamos
falando muito mais do que alguns
imaginam que a gerar mapa ou quando nós
pensamos nos nossos municípios é mais do
que conectores interligados e utilizando
sistemas de informações sejam sistemas
gerenciais ou sistemas de informações
geográficas
só que quando eu falei de inteligência
geográfica que eu falei do que a
geografia tecnologia não é e tecnologia
não é aquilo que ascende que pisca as
tecnologias são técnicas apropriadas
pelo ser humano para transformação e
talvez um exemplo melhor temos aqui
vários instrumentistas provavelmente na
platéia nos assistindo você tem aí a
foto do bb king a gente poderia colocar
outros grandes guitarristas mas qual é a
diferença de um guitarrista deste pra
nós se tentarmos agora começamos a tocar
a técnica legal
a tecnologia que utiliza eu não tenho
uma guitarra como a dele não
mas na verdade a apropriação das suas
técnicas e tecnologias para a
transformação do seu meio bb king como
outros não nasceram com um braço de
madeira e com co
de aço então ele utiliza guitarra como
forma de expressão do seu momento espaço
tempo como nós devemos fazer com as
nossas cidades apropriação de espaço
tempo não da tecnologia somente para
conectar sensores ou para informar onde
estão as pessoas
oprah denunciam mas como nós podemos
transformar esse nosso meio
alguns de vocês estão pensando mas isso
é muito recente sim tão recente quanto
antigo egito quando os antigos já
analisavam todo o ciclo de vazão das do
reuni lo para entender qual o momento de
plantar o momento de escolher se aquele
local deve ser o culpado não é incrível
nós não respeitamos a área de vários até
hoje e os antigos egípcios já tinham
estudos mostrando alguns agora estão
pensando já foi citado numa das
palestras desse dia de hoje mobilidade
assim mobilidade um problema muito ao
nosso né
sim o atual quanto na antiga roma quando
já existia inclusive horários para
entrega aqui nós temos um entregador em
cima do horário vai acabar com o rodízio
ele tem que entregar a tempo isso nós já
tínhamos os planos de ordenamento de
mobilidade
todas as estradas levam a roma então nós
estamos falando que os problemas que nós
temos hoje nas cidades e se a gente for
analisar e psicologicamente a sua origem
são problemas ou fatos que acompanham
toda a história da humanidade agora qual
é a grande diferença para o nosso
momento atual
nós vivemos hoje num mundo digital
nós vivemos cidades digitais
aliás isso é uma cidade isso é uma
imagem de um processador i7
nós estamos então aqui falando que não
não o digital a diferença a diferença é
que estamos gerando muita informação
para o tempo que é o mesmo desde os
antigos egípcios mas a taxa de conversão
nisso em conhecimento é muito baixa
então é falarmos sobre essa apropriação
da inteligência geográfica
qual é a forma de expressão ou de
análise disso os mapas
só que mapas antes eram alguns né
o professor de geografia que sabia
desenhar todo o mapa mundi hidrografia o
mercato todo mundo lembra dele a
groelândia sistema de projeção maior
groelândia do que a áfrica
nós estamos falando aqui dos mapas do
brasil são incríveis hoje eu pego esses
mapas que foram feitos com técnicas
iniciais da cartografia a gente tenta
casar isso com uma imagem de satélite é
muito é perfeito e quase perfeito esse
levantamento que eu quero dizer com isso
se mapas antes eram para alguns
alguns devem está pensando agora então
mapas hoje são para todos cheguei aqui
utilizando um dispositivo de si não são
mapas para todos
a informação geográfica a
disponibilidade da informação geográfica
hoje é pra todos vejam só alguns de
vocês devem conhecer ali uma ferramenta
chamada minecraft que se vocês não
entendem os filhos sobrinhos de vocês
entendem muito bem ea formação cerebral
espacial que está ocorrendo neste
momento nas redes sociais compartilhando
eles estão construindo e desconstruindo
cidades
nós temos simuladores e aqui eu tenho
uma imagem que o capturou ontem à noite
né
aqui da praça conhece aquele joguinho
chamado pokémon que muitos consideravam
a bobeira essa galera que perde tempo
com essas coisas
agora onde o poder no topo remón go mas
o poder que eu tenho na mão das pessoas
para que nós possamos nos apropriar das
cidades não só com dados geográficos não
só gerando mapas mas que nós possamos
vivenciar essa cidade ou seja se nós
hoje ouvimos falar da internet das
coisas
a provocação aqui porque não falarmos da
geografia das coisas ou seja e mais do
que das coisas porque nós estamos
trazendo a humanidade a esse sentido
quando trago dispositivos essa é uma
foto lá de são josé dos campos cidade
onde eu moro num domingo numa praça
milhares a ir a centenas de jovens
adultos crianças interagindo com os
sistemas
mas isso aqui é brincadeira imagina o
poder que nós temos na mão dessa
população
eu sempre cito a gente tem muitas
cidades com problemas por exemplo de
arborização árvores que caíram
imagina só um game na cidade onde cada
criança da escola sai da seu quarteirão
e mapeia a sua árvore por exemplo em
quanto tempo a gente tem todas as
árvores da cidade mapeadas
nós estamos falando aqui de vivência e
não simplesmente de satélites drones
dados interconectados em sistemas
virtuais e digitar não conhecem esse
sujeito
esse é o doutor john snow não aquele da
série oc totalizou foi disruptivo na sua
visão de medicina porque lá num dos
surtos de cólera em londres em 1853 mais
do que coletar dados sobre as mortes de
cólera
mais do que indicar que pra ele as
doenças não eram necessariamente
transmitidas pelo ar que era a teoria
vigente médica naquele momento ele foi a
campo ele foi vivenciar transformar
território lugar entender e levantar
onde estão as pessoas que morreram e
como naquele momento a distribuição de
água era por bombas d'água ele também
mapeou as bombas d'água e ele conseguiu
fazer uma análise que não foi colocar
pontinho no mapa que hoje seria não foi
simplesmente a denunciar a prefeitura
que tem um buraco
ele está falando ali de vivência porque
ele consegue aqui já no sistema digital
né ele consegue transformar dados em
informação e informação em conhecimento
unindo espaço tempo eu gosto do
subtítulo do livro que conta a história
do doutor john snow que fala o seguinte
como a luta de dois homens contra o
cólera foi doutor jon snow reverendo and
white head mudou o destino das nossas
metrópoles porque foi a partir desses
estudos que nós começamos a discutir
saneamento básico distribuição de água
ou seja 11 mil dispositivos daquele
espaço tempo naquele momento no ranking
caneta campo uniu vivência
temos que ouvir a sociedade são alguns
inclusos nos últimos não sei nem se
meses ou semanas de algumas reportagens
que eu acabei sendo chamado para dar
algum tipo de opinião como especialista
eu posso utilizar essa tal de
inteligência geográfica ou seja unir
geografia com tecnologia para tornados
eu posso ouvir isso pra fazer um
aplicativo sem física para denunciar
onde eu tenho não tenho casos de
execução de dengue enfim eu posso o
vejam eu tenho vários exemplos
eu quero mostrar aqui que não é já foi
até dito isso no outro sentido não é o
fetiche tecnológico não é a cidade as
pessoas utilizarem ferramentas técnicas
porque é bacana e divertido é legal mas
sim por que a sociedade tenha esse
anseio lembra o nosso começo da
discussão
nós estamos falando de cidades o que
elas têm em comum o tempo e espaço que
integrados geram conhecimento então nós
estamos ouvindo a sociedade e se hoje
somos seres que estão interconectados
houve até um pedido para todos tem
alguns que estão tremendo neste momento
na platéia porque estão os smartphones
desligados né porque não utilizarmos os
sistemas de informação sejam eles
informar sistemas de informações
geográficas sistema de informações
gerenciais ou seja vamos utilizar
plataformas digitais não como alguns de
vocês aqui que estão representando já
conhecem não é fazer o geoprocessamento
da cidade não é fazer o
georreferenciamento é entender o momento
histórico atual em que nós podemos
integrar dispositivos vivência em
sociedade e sistemas de informação para
que juntos nós possamos mais do que
falar da internet das coisas de cidades
inteligentes ou de qualquer outro
smartphone vai só smart seja lá o que
for
mas nós levarmos uma reflexão sobre a
sociedade não futura mas a sociedade que
já se apresenta hoje uma sociedade que
já utiliza esses dispositivos não mais
como tira isso da mão eu ouço alguns
professores como eu desligo esse
smartphone na sala de aula não prof
sou é você que tem entender como se
apropriar dessas novas técnicas desse
novo momento para que nós possamos nos
apropriar dele transformá lo da melhor
maneira e mais do que uma maneira
técnica ou de uma maneira gerencial ou
de uma já maneira de gestão somente mas
colaborativamente permitindo que nós
como seres digitais nos tornemos somente
avatares do mundo não somente como
alguns proclamar alguns anos atrás que
isso derrubaria a interconectividade
entre as pessoas reais mais estamos
criando os novos tipos de conexão e pra
isso mais do que as cidades inteligentes
campo inteligente
nós buscamos cidadãos conscientes
conscientes do seu tempo espaço que é
transformado incorporado e modificado
muito obrigado pela atenção